[Music]
[Applause]
Dan orlovski of the mothership part of
NFL live you can watch Monday through
Friday at 4 Eastern on
ESPN um it feels like most of the talk
in the first couple of days after these
games over the weekend have to do with
people defending or criticizing Josh
Allen or defending or criticizing Brock
perie
yeah
why uh well I think I mean obviously I
was on the whole day Monday doing the
defending of Josh I I think part of or
the focal point for the defending or
conversation around Josh is it doesn't
make sense if you're a sports person
that he's lost you know that that's the
that's the part where you sit there and
go sports usually is the the meritocracy
like you get what you deserve or you get
what you earn at some point maybe not
all the time but at some point and you
know for so many instances in that
matchup that quarterback has played to a
level you sit there and say absolutely
deserves to win the game or absolutely
has earned that win and for the third
time in a row you sit there and go it
didn't happen you know and and he became
a lightning rod this year because of the
conversation of turnovers and and
everyone that was you know trying to
make that the focal point of his game
and so I think it just became this this
overwhelming conversation because if
Josh had turn thrown the know two
interceptions on on Sunday night's game
it would have been different but he
played at such a remarkable level that
it became this like well dude you should
win that game but then the the crowd
that wants to you know hate on them use
well you lost and then I think for Brock
pie I mean there's a reality Danny
didn't play good for the first you know
three plus quarters and so you know for
the crowd that isn't the Brock py group
it's well I Told You So or finally we
got there and then he has the
game-winning drive and everyone's like
well gamewinner you know that has to
matter at some point so um it's kind of
what you're going into narrative fits
around but also I think that we want
Josh Allen to be on the same level as
Patrick
Mahomes like we're yeah I mean because
we're wishing that we're wishing that um
yeah and and he's probably on the level
with Lamar Jackson he's not on the level
with Patrick mAh
like like ju just like you I'm talking
about success I mean Lamar hasn't done
anything in the playoffs but he's got
two MVPs but it it just feels like we're
trying to create a Brady Manning you
know Marino uh Montana like we want that
it's just we want competition for momes
and it's just not there yeah I'm I I
love Patrick this is Patrick's fault
though you know it's there is that
reality I say that all the time you know
it's that's why some kids get drafted in
the first round I I go it's Patrick's
fault you know so Patrick is this he's
the guy to blame for this yeah I mean
but but to put that into context right
he's not on Patrick's level if Patrick's
a 10 out of 10 or a 100 out of 100 he is
the next number down Josh Allen and it's
fair to say that he's not on that level
because he hasn't had that playoff win
or whatnot but the numbers and
performances would say that he is you
know like that's that's the hard part of
that Dan is like the when you have when
you're 0 and three versus a guy in the
playoffs but those three playoff runs
you have 22 touchdowns and one
interception you go how yeah when you're
a guy who's got two seasons of 50 plus
touchdowns and not in the championship
game you go how you're the only person
ever so yeah he he it we can't put him
on Patrick's level um but it's not like
it's you know a level that is in such a
distance and I think part of it too is
you know the Bills fan base as much as
you might hate
sports or you might hate your Rivals fan
bases I think a lot of people root for
the bills a lot of people root for their
fan base a lot of people root because of
some of their playoff mishaps in the
past and so it's a lot and the way the
game ended you know if the 13 second
game from a couple years ago you're like
there's no humanly possible way this
past week if they got beat 35 to 10
we're not having these conversations you
you know if or if that field goal goes
in and Patrick drives them down and they
get a game-winning field goal we're not
having these these conversations it's
also attached to how the game ended
tougher to defend when they're at their
Peak Lamar Jackson or Patrick
Mahomes yes um you know I I still I
still would say Patrick um and I would
say
Patrick both of them are guys that you
could have the perfect play call as a
defensive coordinator all 11 people on
your defense could play it absolutely
perfect and it wouldn't didn't matter
both of them are in that group Patrick
because Patrick has made more you should
not do that throws than Lamar has for me
um Lamar's probably made more oh my gosh
runs than Patrick has um and I've also
seen Patrick do it in the moment you
know and so I I would probably say
Patrick but again it's not far off how
do the Lions get to the Super
Bowl uh number one you I don't I said
this I don't know who's calling that
game I don't know what analyst is
calling it they're going to use the
phrase pin pull in Choice a ton that's a
run scheme you know you pin the outside
you pull guys around San Francisco is
vulnerable to that everybody that has
played San Francisco tough and beaten
them has has had success with that
Arizona did Green Bay had a 100 yards on
just that run last week Detroit major in
it they love it so Detroit's got to
dominate in that aspect number two
Jared's got to tow the line between
between like being reactive and
proactive I've seen Jared become
reactive in these moments and you don't
want him to be reactive you want him to
be proactive move people with your eyes
trust what they're telling you and then
they got three guys that what they run
what we call Choice rout stand so they
you you give these guys just the
opportunity hey go get open type stuff
so it's leaport Gibbs and Aman raw and
all that's rare most teams have won
mcaffrey for San Francisco is really the
guy um if those three guys are really
good and that route concept it's hard to
not like get open and hard to defend I
think if they can be really good in that
they
win I think the big concern with the
Niners has been that front like they
they don't get at after people the way I
mean they have the names to get after
people but they haven't that to me has
been alarming yeah both lines of
scrimmage you know H have to be a
concern if you're kaenan because their
defensive line has not dominated advant
Detroit I I think this is I could very
much so see this being a game where we
come outgoing my goodness Detroit's
offensive line you you can't dominate a
football game more and I think that's
the the the the Viewpoint if you're Ben
Johnson and and Dan Campbell um and
again I think for everybody at home
who's try watch runs out on the
perimeter out on the edge and then you
know their defensive line I would tell
you this too their right tackle he is
going to get a full game of Aiden
Hutchinson if I was Aaron Glenn and
who's been great as a defensive
coordinator Aiden Hutchinson is going to
get as many one on-one opportunities
versus San Francisco's right tackle is
possible and that's Advantage Detroit we
talking to Dan orlovski of the Mother
Ship you can catch him on NFL live
Monday through Friday at 4 Eastern on
ESPN you came out same year that Joe Mau
came out of high school yeah that right
this is this is yes same same year this
a dead honest story Tom leming was doing
he was like the big high school
recruiting guy that he had that the Tom
leming report magazine all that stuff
this is in 2000 maybe 2000 um and I
remember I had to go up to do a photo
shoot for his magazine and you're
looking through the names of guys or
whatnot and he just kept talking about
this dude named Joe Mau and so I go to I
think they were the Midwest or whatnot
or the Great Lakes Group or whatever and
I look at his picture and Joe's picture
does not look like a you know thre sport
allam
certainly the number one player in both
Sports and I'm like this dude's the best
quarterback and baseball player in the
country cuz he had this like
Midwestern like almost tpe type of
hairstyle and you're like what and so
yeah he was he was the guy I remember
all of like him he was going to Florida
State to play quarterback and then
obviously picked baseball and whatnot
but he was just he was like known around
the pares because he was so good yeah
and and he picked the right sport
because you can make the most money and
and uh you know have long like Jeff smar
with Notre D yeah yeah Joe was the
number one pick right Joe ma ended up
being the number one pick for Minnesota
yeah yeah yeah I think he I yeah he
picked the uh the right right sport all
right you could take bellich or
Harbaugh Harbaugh okay not even close
for me it when it comes to like for my
viewpoint he's the best quarterback
developer we have in the game that's
available certainly he's I mean we talk
about Josh Johnson and then Alex Smith
and then Colin Kaepernick um and then
obviously what he's done with JJ
McCarthy he's the best quarterback
developer when it comes to how we get
these guys to play at their very best so
I I I would be a little bit concerned in
regards to with coach bellich and how
poorly it went with M Jones obviously
he's got the Tom Brady in his belt as
well but are you bringing those people
that developed Tom Brady like who is he
bringing with him in regards to his
offensive staff I think is a huge part
of that
conversation it's there what do you
think the odds are that belich gets
frozen out here that maybe he's not a
head coach this next
season um I still don't know I I still
see him getting a job somewhere you know
like obviously we'll see what happens
with Coach Harbaugh whatnot um you
continue to hear coach bellich chic's
name around Atlanta I I would be
surprised if he gets frozen out but
again I don't know you've heard these
conversations from the outside of hey
look at his staff everyone I get hit up
by people excuse me of like look at K
coach belck staff look at his staff look
at his staff and that's the weak part
and so you you gotta who's goingon to be
his offensive coordinator because Bill
O'Brien's in Penn State is it gonna be
Josh I I don't know so I think that's
part of that well I also wonder with the
Chargers because Harbaugh would be great
I think Pete Carroll back in Southern
California running the Chargers would
make more I can't see Bill going to the
commanders uh the Raiders job is closed
you got Atlanta he not GNA do Carolina I
don't think right it feels like Atlanta
right yeah Atlanta and that's it yeah
but it feels like okay two interviews it
has it gone on a little because you can
hire him right now has it gone on a
little too
long I mean it has for me where I have
more doubt now
than I did
before yeah I mean I think the whole
conversation around coach beler one of
the most important ones I you know
really from the jump has been how much
say he wants in Personnel you know the
the the last 10 drafts in New England
have been bad so Terry font who the
general manager in Atlanta is he giving
up power to select is he giving up power
in final say how much does you know
coach belich want I've I said this
yesterday Dan I you've been around it
longer than me and I don't pay attention
to it or certainly haven't as much but
you know the more that maybe some of
these conversations or calls come in for
me as well like does this coaching cycle
just feel like it's taken a long time I
feel like teams have moved faster in the
past than they are right now and I know
Aaron Glenn and Ben Johnson are very
much so still in that conversation Todd
monin so maybe they're waiting on those
guys but I don't know how many
interviews have you had with
teams oh um
I don't know if they're full interviews
yet you know I'm still in the season or
whatnot I've I've been I've had
conversations and been hit up by people
in teams yes um but I I haven't dove
into you know full full go interview or
anything like that well how does that
work though they just reach out I get
reached out to okay yeah you get reached
out to and said hey you know this is
this is the vision um you know whether
staying or going somewhere would love to
sit down and talk with you about a role
in some capacity title is always
something that nowadays you know it's a
I guess like a fluid conversation or or
maybe not necessarily a very specific
thing but you just get contacted by
people and hey what's your interest
level all that stuff it's always very
very very flattering well you can't get
that kind of competition sitting in a
sterile Studio you you can never
replicate that after you get done
playing but this is as close as you're
going to get so I certainly understand
what that P could be that draw but you
do have you have you have a great job
it's like I you know remember telling
John guden like if you give up Monday
Night Football you won't get it back
yeah yeah no no doubt I I I love my job
I love working for ESPN I love working
for people like Burke Magnus and Jimmy
pataro and those dudes have been awesome
for me and I love working with the
people that I get to work with I do say
this though um and I'm very aware of how
fortunate I
am the more I get away from being done
playing the greater the pull back to it
just because of the competitive drive
you know like Lewis rck and I walked the
field with Fowler every time we do a
Monday night football game and Lewis
always gets to the point and we'll kind
of look at each other and he always says
like man you can't this is the best you
you you you your juices just get going
and it's all you know and you know it's
it's that that pull to be a part of that
is is um you know I don't know if it'll
ever go away but I can say it certainly
getss stronger as the years go on well
good luck with the Seahawks
Dan Seattle I'll tell you this when you
fly to Seattle you feel like you're
flying to Mars man you are out there so
but if you live there you don't have to
fly there that's a good point good point
good to talk to you thank you Dan you
too bud thank you Dan orlovsky of the
mothership part of NFL live Monday
through Friday at 4 Eastern